good morning John and good morning to
the class of 2017 and also all of the
other classes and people who aren't in
classes here's what I think it's
probably up with most you what was up
with me you have done the thing other
people have told you to do for your
entire life and now you don't know what
to do because guess what freedom is
awful and I can't decide what to have
for dinner
much less what to do with the rest of my
life you have an infinite number of
paths ahead of you pick join the army or
the Peace Corps or the clergy go to grad
school or business school or a horoscope
school where astrologers go to school
will do side hustles and start a podcast
and follow your dreams until you realize
that your dreams aren't actually that
great because work has much more to do
with the people you do it with in your
own attitude than whatever it is you're
actually doing I loved science and I got
a job doing science after I graduated
and it was miserable not because I
didn't like the science it's because I
was the only person in the lab all the
time just me and my pipettes and a
family of armadillos and a giant
canister of liquid nitrogen and yes that
sounds kind of awesome but after six
months if you are very lucky you have
discovered something you like doing it
is very easy to get through life without
discovering a saleable skill that you
enjoy and that is by the way how dream
jobs actually happen you find a thing
that you like doing at least most of the
time and you do it enough that you get
good enough at it that people will pay
you to do it so if you like doing a
thing that has economic value continue
doing that thing you are one of the
lucky ones if you don't welcome to being
most people to you I offer only this you
are normal we evolved for a world so
unlike the one that we find ourselves in
that it is amazing any of us can
function at all humans are above
everything adaptable but the idea that
any of this stuff careers and job
interviews and diplomas and the jobs
themselves is like a normal human
construction that like that year-old
designed to do then it's crazy it's all
brand-new super weird cultural
constructions that didn't exist like 300
years ago this stuff all seems very
normal it's not and if you base your
self-worth on it which we do we are
asked
it's what society says our value is but
if you do you it's gonna be real hard to
be happy you don't need a job that
changes the world and that's
environmentally friendly and that is
creatively fulfilling in every way and
that uses any diploma much less the
diploma that you happen to have you need
to feel valuable it put all of the
different constraints that is being
placed on like what a valuable life
looks like it's nuts it's way too much
to expect from anyone much less everyone
it takes so long to get it in your head
you didn't go to school to learn how to
get a job you went to school to learn
and you did it you know more stuff now
so you might never know what you're
doing but do me this favor get out of
bed every morning knowing that no one
changes the world alone and no one
doesn't change it at all we are all
exceptional and none of us are and we
are all lost sometimes so follow a path
any path until you get to a place did
you feel like you don't like and then
change your direction because there's
one thing that you are making every day
no matter what you're doing and that is
yourself that is your job
and you must do it well for me there's a
lot of strength in knowing that the
wandering that I am doing that I've done
is normal and kind of beautiful and not
something I should be stressed out about
you're on a path you don't know where
it's going and that would be boring if
you did John I'll see you on Tuesday
here is the current list of people who
will be a pod con just an update pod can
calm